Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Easy.
Oh Leute, heute nur High IQ Chat, bitteschön.
Ich sehe schon, die High IQ Chatter sind natürlich auch wieder als erstes da.
heute mindest iq für den chat 80 plus
ach guck mal guck mal da sind ein paar leute schon eine ganze weile nicht mehr gesehen aber
wieder erfolgt ja ist wieder am start der umut ist auch mal wieder am start
300 kg ja du hast bestimmt schweres gehirn oder
daran muss das liegen
Geht der direkt ins Rückenmark oder wie?
So, ich muss mal kurz Package-Updates machen.
Neues Katzenvideo gucke ich nachher.
Ich muss mal Package-Updates gerade schnell machen, weil sonst vergesse ich das wieder.
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Was ist hier? Warum ist es kaputt?
Was ist da schon wieder?
C-Doppelpunkt-User-Stream-4M-Stream.
Aha, ich weiß, was er hat.
Chat, ich bin dumm. Ich habe vergessen zu gucken.
Wo war die 4M?
vms aha stream vms da muss man nämlich dass das funktioniert es
packt manchmal mit vm warum da muss man diese diese log files löschen guck hier
alles mit log muss man dann löschen und sobald man dann wieder drauf geht da zack bumm funktioniert
so erst mal package updates machen wir machen heute beide wir machen heute keine set servers
und wir machen auch kein august stellt also auch kein java kram oder dort net kram oder
go kram oder irgendwas wir schwätzen einfach nur ein bisschen ich habe eine ganze ecke zeit hier
bis 21 oder so 69 der IQ ne nur 80 plus übrigens wusste ihr dass ein IQ unter 70
als Behinderung gilt in Deutschland kann man sich einen Behindertenausweis holen
oder unter 80 könnte sogar unter 80 sein aber python heute wird nichts geproggert
machen wir aber ich habe mir das angeguckt gibt er jede menge neue sachen gibt bestimmt
keine 30 neue szenarien oder so die wir noch nicht gemacht haben und ich hoffe dass das jetzt
gefixt ist das wenn ich aus versehen die url zeige sich leute da irgendwie oder beurte die
ip dass ich leute darauf einloggen können und so was war ganz gut champ kriegt man eigentlich mit
Zertifikaten mehr Geld, nicht automatisch.
Kommt drauf an, wie du das
Ganze verkaufst.
Wenn das ein Job ist,
die unbedingt was haben, also, dass
du den nur kriegst, wenn du ein Zertifikat hast, aber das
hab ich persönlich noch nie erlebt.
Dass das
irgendwie, ich sag nicht, dass es das
nicht gibt, ja. Ich sag nur, dass ich
das noch nicht erlebt hab und auch noch nicht davon gehört
oder mitbekommen hab, dass
die irgendwie gesagt haben, oh ja,
der Bewerber ist ja eigentlich nice, passt alles,
aber der hat hier das zertifikat nicht deswegen wollen wir nicht also das habe
ich noch nicht gehört mag sicherlich geben aber ihr wisst ich halte nichts
großartig von zertifizierung und zertifikaten das ist so ein
selbsterhaltendes gelddruck quasi quasi die lizenz zum geld drucken für die
hersteller und die ganzen schulungs leute und so was die meisten schulungen
die ich gemacht habe waren hochgradig unsinnig zum beispiel also eins muss
mir sagen wir benutzen eine software bei uns auf der arbeit wie kann man das beschreiben wofür die
da ist das ist das so eine security software die kann zum beispiel an die denn da kann man
so audit zeug mitmachen so also wenn ich jetzt also wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise mich heute
heute abend auf dem produktivsystem einloggen und dort daten runter kopiere
und die im darknet verkaufe dann könnten die über diese software feststellen dass
ich das wohl gewesen bin so sie so ein audit ding ist das zum
größten teil zumindest ich sage nicht wie die heißt aber zumindest der
hersteller hat wirklich die lizenz zum geld drucken erfunden und zwar die haben
ihre lizenzbedingungen trainer stehen dass wenn jemand die software als bei uns ist es so du kannst
quasi keine server administrieren und nichts ohne dass du die software da zumindest durchgehst
irgendwie mario lang stoffe den sub also jetzt heißt jeder der dort anfängt benutzt mehr oder
weniger die software wenn auch nicht direkt dann indirekt weil er halt damit gelockt wird und so
was und damit du das überhaupt darfst steht in den lizenzbedingungen trainer dass der mitarbeiter
eine schulung bei denen besucht haben muss das heißt die haben wirklich die haben wirklich den
den trick den infinite money klitsch erfunden die haben nicht nur eine teure software mit teurem
mit teurer lizenz jeder neue mitarbeiter muss dann auch noch für frag mich nicht wie viel 100
euro so eine komische drei tages schulung machen dass er das überhaupt benutzen darf und es ist
jetzt nicht so als ist die software so krass kompliziert dass man die nicht kapiert wenn man
die schulung nicht gemacht hat aber das ist das ist next level und das ist wirklich drei tage
ich musste die auch machen drei tage schulung da kriegst du zeug gezeigt wie du das ding aufsetzt
und was da im admin hinter ich will das ding nicht administrieren ist jetzt das ding auch nicht auf
ich klicke höchstens mal im web interface rum aber nee du musst diese jeder neue mitarbeiter
muss diese schulung besucht haben so ehrlich das ist dieses microsoft
eschel audit ding das kann ja das ist es nicht so toolbox wird glaube ich da
leider gibt es eine neue version würde ich sagen wir gleich was ist hier los
erstmal IQ-Test
uploaden hier.
80 plus heute.
Ich durfte
diese Woche erfahren,
dass Burn nicht in
KI-Software trainiert werden und es dennoch benutzen.
Ja und? Ich glaube jeder von uns
hat schon mal zumindest Chat-GPT
oder so benutzt, ohne da drin trainiert
gewesen zu sein.
Und es ist trotzdem noch keiner gestorben? Wobei, man weiß es nicht. Doch, doch, ist doch einer gestorben. Da habe ich doch irgendwas gelesen. Irgendeiner hat sich doch Medikamenten-Advice oder was war das? Bei Chat-GPT geholt. Und hat dann irgendwas eingeschmissen, was ihm Chat-GPT empfohlen hat.
Ja, also manche Leute sind auch nicht mehr zu retten, ey.
Über was ich heute reden will, keine Ahnung, weiß ich noch nicht.
Videos können wir auch gucken.
Ich könnte vielleicht sagen, jetzt nochmal, nachdem ich jetzt drei oder vier Java-Streams gemacht habe,
dass ich das viel besser finde, als ich ursprünglich gedacht habe.
Wann kommt nächstes YouTube-Video?
Ähm, morgen.
She paid it.
ich weiß noch nicht so gut ist durch
so firefox bester browser
So, jetzt haben wir Package-Updates gemacht.
Nicht, dass wir das jetzt brauchen würden, aber
Arch, by the way,
das muss
Bleeding Edge sein.
Leute, war das nicht so,
dass man, ne, was?
Screen Fetch darf man nicht mehr benutzen, oder?
Oder war es Neo Fetch,
was man nicht mehr benutzen darf?
Was nicht mehr supported wird?
Keine Ahnung.
weiß ich wenn die irgendwelche sensiblen daten in so ein ich will nicht wissen was leute alles
in chat gpt rein copy pasted mittlerweile da wird wahrscheinlich alles möglich drin gelandet
sein irgendwelche vom arzt irgendwelche dinger von der bank irgendwelche dinger alles mögliche
wird wird da drin die privatesten sachen wenn der leute rein copy pasted haben passwörter
irgendwelche
merkwürdigen Fantasien.
Keine Ahnung. Ich glaube,
in Chat-GPT,
man muss sich ja auch nicht wundern, dass Chat-GPT
angeblich, oder beziehungsweise AI,
gab es ja letztens, da habe ich mal so einen Artikel gelesen,
dass AI immer dümmer wird. Ja, das wundert mich
nicht. Wenn es nach dem geht, was da reingepumpt
wird, dann kann es ja nur dümmer werden.
Fastfetch
ist es. Fastfetch.
Ha! Du hast recht.
Du hast recht, weil
Guck mal, Neo Fetch
Ist Alias bei mir auf Fast Fetch
Du hast recht
Ich weiß nur, dass ich mir Fast Fetch
Nicht merken kann, deswegen habe ich es gealiast
Och net schau wieder, Alter
Das Spammen geht mir ja mal echt
Massive auf den Sack, Alter
Spannen
Spam
Block.
Äh.
Fuck.
Warum hat denn das Blocken nicht funktioniert?
So, jetzt aber.
Jetzt aber.
Zu den ganzen Bot-Spammern kann ich nur sagen.
Piss dich, Aldo.
Hast du schon Veränderungen der Debian schon mitbekommen?
Ja, habe ich mitbekommen und es hat mich auch schon übelst abgefuckt,
dass Debian jetzt ein neues Repo-List-Format hat.
Wer das nicht kennt, ich zeige euch das mal.
Debian Repo-List New Format.
Das ist jetzt so mehrzeilig.
Das ist richtig dumm.
Examples.
Ja, guck.
Das ist jetzt nicht mehr eine Zeile,
die man richtig schön per se oder sonst was editieren konnte.
Das ist jetzt so ein mehrzeiliges Ding.
Das ist richtig abartig.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum.
Ich habe wirklich legit keinen Plastenschimmer.
Vielleicht, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es gute Gründe hat.
Gerade die Debian-Leute machen ja nicht ein Ubuntu
und packen irgendwelches random sinnlos Zeug rein.
Aber das verstehe ich nicht, warum es das gibt.
Ja, das hat mich auch schon abgefuckt
Guck
So sah das früher aus
Und so
So sieht das jetzt aus
Im Zweifelsfall war das der System D Typ
Glaube ich aber nicht
Könnte ich mir aber durchaus vorstellen
also das verstehe ich nicht das ist das wirklich eklig ich habe da mal versucht in einem docker
fall was sossen zu editieren und also mit einem seht so erzeugt search and replace das war mit
diesem neuen format so krass abartig bis das funktioniert hat das liegt daran dass die linux
foundation beschlossen hat das zu vereinheitlichen für die distros wie
sollen die das vereinheitlichen die distros sind doch komplett unterschiedlich was package
management angeht oder meinste dem man würde dann hier quasi ach hier guck mal hier steht
der types debian und so also hier würde dann drin ist den type rpm url auf irgendein rpm
Mirror oder sowas.
Hast du eigentlich gesehen, wie Zuckerberg
bei seiner Demo auf die Fresse geflogen ist?
Nee.
Nee, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Wobei ich ja sagen muss,
das ist eines meiner Lieblingsverschwörungstheorien.
Das ist ja angeblich ein Echsenmensch.
Genauso wie Obamas Bodyguard
Keck Alu
Was meinst du so
LPG-1
Also
Ich kann dir da keine
Ja so
Erfahrungen aus erster Hand liefern
Ich hab mal ein paar LPG-1 Tests gemacht
So
So Probedinger
Die waren aber glaube ich auch ganz schön veraltet
schon zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich die gemacht habe.
Das ist schon eine ganze Weile her, aber
in dem Test wurde noch nach Lilo gefragt,
anstatt nach Krupp und so für Bootmanager
ganz weirdchampig.
Elpig ist so ein Ding,
dass eines der wenigen Sachen, wo ich
sagen muss, das finde ich gar nicht so
blöde, weil es doch relativ
klar zeigt, dass man zumindest Basic Linux
Skills hat. Und manche Sachen,
die Anfragen, die ich da gesehen habe,
sind auch gar nicht so einfach gewesen.
Weil es halt auch wieder ist,
bringt es das wirklich, wenn man alles
da auswendig kann ist es nicht viel wichtiger dass man weiß was man suchen
muss ich weiß nicht also epic 1 finde ich noch irgendwie ansatzweise sinnvoll
aber ihr wisst sich halt von den ganzen zertifikaten nix hättest du längere
pause gemacht wie läuft so im leben auf der arbeit auf der arbeit läuft gut im
leben lief das war ja auch der grund warum ich nicht geschrieben habe im
leben lief es nicht so gut seit einem halben jahr ungefähr so seit oktober november letztes jahr
wird boxe neues vor allem wir wollen wir mit desktop virtualisierung und desktop für desktop
virtualisierung immer vor allem wer workstation würde ich also würde ich persönlich immer wird
schulbox vorziehen bist du immer noch der forbes nein bin ich nicht ich habe ja mal
Arbeitgeber gewechselt vor zweieinhalb Jahren ungefähr und jetzt bin ich Senior Linux Engineer.
Ich werde aber demnächst, jetzt haltet euch fest, Senior Site Reliability Engineer. Klingt doll, oder?
Das ist jetzt der neueste Shit. Ja.
zuvor oder
was auch immer das heißt das muss man nicht wissen haupt nach man hat in seinem in seinem
job titel drin stehen dann kann man das hinzu kann man es direkt in lebenslauf aufnehmen nur
Nur Titel Upgrade oder auch mehr Geld?
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Also weder Upgrade noch mehr Geld.
Das wird einfach umbenannt.
Die wollen sich, glaube ich, einfach ein bisschen, ja, ein bisschen moderneren Anstrich noch geben.
So interpretiere ich das.
Und deswegen benennen die das halt um.
Weder mehr Geld noch Upgrade.
Das ist einfach nur ein Jobbezeichnungs-Renaming.
weil das andere ist hin zu oldschool
sollen so machen ist mir ganz recht kann ich den lebenslauf schreiben falls ich mal wieder
irgendwann mal brauchen sollte denke ja nicht ja mein chef hat mir auch letztens erzählte
hoffentlich bleibt noch eine weile da habe ich auch vorher will er nicht weg das wirklich also
das muss ich jetzt echt mal sagen wie gefällt es richtig gut bei meinem neuen arbeit neu ist
der ja auch nicht mehr bei meinem jetzt muss man sagen bei meinem jetzigen arbeitgeber und was da
auch ein riesenvorteil ist wirst es dem alten das habe ich glaube ich schon 500 mal erzählt
aber das stelle ich immer wieder fest weil beim alten arbeitgeber war es so dass dort wurden
führungskräfte quasi ausgewählt nachdem wir bei drei nicht auf dem baum war ich war glücklicherweise
bei drei immer auf dem baum auch wenn mir mein chef damals paar mal erzählt hat was für tolle
karrieremöglichkeiten es da gibt ich sowas wollte ich nie machen und würde ich auch immer noch nicht
machen wollen aber von meinem neuen arbeitgeber werden nicht die leute chef oder teamleiter oder
sowas in der richtung die nicht bei drei auf baum sind sondern wirklich die leute dies machen wollen
und die auch schon ein paar jahre immer mal wieder kurse dafür besucht haben und nicht direkt ins
kalte wasser geschmissen werden was dazu führt dass dort die führungskräfte im durchschnitt
einfach viel besser sind als bei meinem alten arbeitgeber und was sie da auch
machen was ich so auch nicht kannte was ich aber eigentlich ziemlich sinnvoll
finde ist die führungskräfte bewerten einmal im jahr quasi ihre ist aber du
bist teamleiter die bewährten einem können einmal im jahr können die ihre
team member bewerten gibt es eine bewertungs matrix so macht zu wenig wir
sind zufrieden über erfüllt das und sowas habe ich übrigens letztens letztens gehabt also ich
stehe ganz gut da bei beiden bei vielen sachen bin mache ich sogar zu viel angeblich aber bin
ich nicht so gerecht sein gut leid machen ist nicht verkehrt aber jetzt kommt jetzt kommt nicht
nur dass der teamleiter seine team member bewerten kann nein die team member können auch den team
leiter bewerten und das stadt das spielt dann auch glaube ich irgendwie rein was
die von bonus kriegen und sowas und und und ein paar andere sachen und wenn es
zu schlecht ist müssen die beispielsweise dann auch irgendeinen
führungskräfte workshop besuchen so und so also das finde ich schon ganz gut
gemacht ich kenne es noch vom letzten
arbeitgeber da war das immer sehr einseitig du musst jetzt verlaufen
irgendwie was anhören aber umgedreht kann ging da nie was das finde ich
eigentlich ganz cool ja und dass der umgang dort halt auch viel normaler ist
einfach ja du kannst du kannst du musst dir da nichts ausdenken
du kannst einem chef da einfach sagen was sache ist auch wenn dir irgendeine
auf den keks geht oder so und dann nimmt das dann auch ernst und versucht dann
irgendwas dran zu machen. Also ich finde
es wirklich nicht schlecht. Also ich
bin froh, dass ich vor drei Jahren
gesagt habe, Max,
wechsel mal den Arbeitgeber.
Ich habe jetzt zu einer Bank als Arbeitgeber
gewechselt, sagt hier
der Corny.
Und bin genau zu einer Storming-Phase
hinein. Was ist denn eine Storming-Phase?
Heißt das so viel,
wie es ist gerade unruhig, oder wie?
Würde an deiner Stelle Gehaltserhöhung fordern?
Das mache ich aus zwei Gründen nicht.
Also, ich habe es ja meinem Chef sogar schon angekündigt letztes Jahr,
dass dieses Jahr komme ich damit um die Ecke.
Aber ich mache es aus zwei Gründen nicht.
Erstens habe ich eine gekriegt, Anfang des Jahres,
ohne dass ich was dafür machen musste.
Einfach so.
und ich habe sogar noch einen extra
Bonus Ende letzten Jahres gekriegt
weil ich mir so viel
Mühe gegeben habe, nochmal
einen zweiten Bonus
und
ich
bin
das letzte halbe Jahr halt nicht so richtig
100%ig auf der Höhe
also wenn ich sowas mache, dann will ich das auch machen
zu einer Zeit, wo ich voll da bin
im Kopf, ja, weil ich merke das
selbst, dass ich bei manchen Sachen einfach ein bisschen
verpeilt bin aktuell.
Aber das liegt halt an meiner
Erkrankung, ja, habe ich ja schon hier schon erzählt.
Da ist man
manchmal ein bisschen verpeilt und kann
sich nicht richtig konzentrieren.
Bei uns wären
Fünfe...
Ja, das ist Mist. Das heißt ja auch, ihr habt dann nicht
unbedingt jetzt die Leute, die fähig dafür
sind, sondern die, die im Endeffekt...
Ja, wie ist es bei euch?
Die, die
besonders gut schleimen können
bei ihrem Chef oder wie?
Oder wie darf man sich das vorstellen?
Also so quasi, welche, die
besonders lang dabei sind und besonders gut
schleimen können beim Chef, wären bei euch Führungskräfte?
Okay.
Also die, die gut Wetter machen
und die, die lange dabei sind.
Lange dabei sein finde ich ja an sich
erstmal nicht verkehrt,
als eines der Kriterien,
weil die den Laden einfach
gut kennen und vor allem halt auch die Führungsriege
und sowas, das finde ich an sich ja gar nicht verkehrt.
Letztendlich musst du ja auch deinen Leuten irgendwie Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten bieten.
Aber das alleine als Kriterium ist natürlich jetzt auch nicht,
zeichnet jetzt ja auch keinen aus, dass er es besonders gut kann.
Es gibt bestimmt genug Leute, die seit 15 Jahren dabei sind,
aber sich null als Führungskraft eignen.
Und vor allem gibt es bestimmt auch genug, die da gar keinen Bock drauf haben.
Das war mal beim alten Arbeitgeber auch so.
Wie gesagt, wer mal drei nicht auf dem Baum war, wurde Führungskraft.
Weil die eben, es wollte keiner machen.
Das spricht jetzt nicht gerade für den alten Arbeitgeber.
dass das das keiner also ihr könnt davon ausgehen wenn bei einem wenn in einem
unternehmen keiner und teamleiter werden möchte dann hat das seinen grund und das
ist meistens kein guter so habe ich nicht gehört jetzt soll ich noch mal
kurz sagen das ist nicht unbedingt das liebt mein absolutes lieblingsthema zum
drüber reden aber ich kann ja mittlerweile darüber reden ja kann ich
nicht so dass ich mich jetzt komplett fertig macht also gut ich sag's ich sag's
noch mal kurz ich habe gemacht dass es wirklich kurz kurz und knackig ich habe
seit ungefähr oktober november letztes jahr hat angefangen mit ich konnte
überhaupt nicht pennen und keiner wusste warum und jetzt ist das alles raus und
ich habe eine angststörung
also was psychisches
und da ist man manchmal nicht so ganz konzentriert dabei
übrigens habe ich gehört man darf angststörung nicht mehr sagen sondern
man sagt heutzutage angsterkrankung wahrscheinlich weil sich wieder irgendeiner
krass diskriminiert dadurch fühlt oder so keine ahnung mich mich juckt das mich
juckt das nicht vor was hast du angst ich mache mir wegen ganz viel zeug
gedanken die eigentlich total unsinnig sind
Das sind so random Dinger.
Mir fällt jetzt gar kein
gescheites Beispiel ein, was ich euch erzählen will.
So komplett sinnlose
random Sachen.
Über die ich mir da teilweise
Gedanken mache.
Das hat tatsächlich
letztes Jahr Oktober, November
angefangen.
und es hat auch eine ganze weile gedauert bis man dann wirklich rausgekriegt hat was da eigentlich
sache ist und ich habe auch erfahren im zuge dessen dass leute die in der it arbeiten wohl
irgendwie sehr an anfällig sind so für psychische sachen scheint scheint öfters vorzukommen einfach
mit humor nehmen ja mache ich auch mittlerweile zumindest soweit es möglich ist ich überlege ob
ob es ein gutes Beispiel gibt.
So sinnlose Sachen, wo ich mir Gedanken drüber mache.
Ja, zum Beispiel. Okay, pass mal auf.
Ich habe ein super Beispiel.
Über was für ein Schwachsinn Sachen ich mir zum Beispiel Gedanken mache.
Ich habe letztens abends eine Tafel Schokolade gefressen.
Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass das was Schlimmes wäre, das ist jetzt auch nichts, was bei Ihnen super gesund wäre oder so.
Aber manchmal überkommt es einen halt.
Und da habe ich mir tatsächlich, und jetzt muss man sich mal vorstellen, wie total hängen geblieben das ist.
Da habe ich mir doch tatsächlich zwei, drei Tage lang in Folge Gedanken drüber gemacht, ob ich jetzt nicht Diabetes kriege, weil ich abends eine Schokolade gefuttert habe.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht mehr normal.
Ja.
Du kriegst kein...
Ich weiß auch, dass es total bescheuert ist.
Das ist aber ganz merkwürdig.
Leute, die vielleicht was ähnliches haben,
können das vielleicht nachvollziehen.
Es ist schwierig nachzuvollziehen.
Man weiß, dass es Schwachsinn ist.
Aber man ist nicht hundertprozentig überzeugt davon,
dass da nichts dran ist.
Ist das was, was man therapieren kann?
Ja.
Kann man, das ist auch schon viel besser.
seit also ich hab's ich hab's eine ganze weile nur mit ja genau man man man
dreht sich im kopf dann wirklich ziemlich viel ziemlich viel im kreis so
und überlegt sich könnte nicht doch noch irgendwas sein also ihr müsst euch das
vorstellen wie ihr denkt an was unangenehmes und die meisten leute
sagen sich naja nicht so wild und können dann weiter weitermachen ja im kopf so
So, also ihr müsst euch das so vorstellen, wie wenn ihr an was Unangenehmes denkt, so nach dem Motto, morgen muss ich zum Zahnarzt oder sowas, ja?
So, nur dass es halt was ist, von dem ihr eigentlich wisst, das ist gar nicht so schlimm.
Oder höchstwahrscheinlich ist eh nix.
Du kriegst keinen Diabetes, nur weil du nur Schokolade gefuttert hast.
Nur, das Ding ist, ihr wisst, dass es Schwachsinn ist, aber ihr seid trotzdem nicht so hundertprozentig überzeugt, dass es wirklich Schwachsinn ist.
Und dann macht man sich zwei, drei Tage Gedanken, ob ich nicht doch Diabetes kriege, weil ich
ein Schokolade gefressen habe oder sowas.
Das geht dann bei mir teilweise so weit, dass ich dann, ich hab dann sogar in meinen Unterlagen
gesucht, vom letzten Blutbild hab ich meinen Blutzucker-Dings mir angeguckt, ob ich nicht
doch Diabetes habe, ohne dass man es gesehen
hat und so was
bescheuertes, ja.
Das ist kein Witz, ja,
so dummes Zeug. Und das Schlimme ist,
das Schlimme ist, Leute, man findet
immer was, man findet
immer was, ja.
Ich hatte im November
oder so ein Blutbild gemacht
für was ganz was anderes
und da hatte ich einen nüchternen Blutzucker,
aber das war nicht nüchtern, muss ich dazu sagen.
Das war nicht nüchtern.
Wir haben ein Blutbild gemacht für was
anderes und das war nachdem ich schon was gefrühstückt hatte so und da hat der arzt auch gesagt den blutzucker den komment komplett ignorieren der
da draufsteht da hatte ich im blutzucker glaube ich von 100 nüchtern blutzucker von 102
normalerweise sagt man unter 100 nüchtern ist okay so über 100 ist schlecht und da habe ich mir ernst habe ich mir ernsthaft gedanken
darüber gemacht ob das jetzt nicht anfangen von diabetes ist
weil ich hatte da doch angeblich blutzucker von 102 morgens aber ich wusste halt auch wieder im gleichen moment
Moment, Max, der Arzt hat doch sogar noch gesagt, den Blutzucker können wir ignorieren, weil ich vorher was gegessen habe.
Und nach Essen ist ein Blutzucker von 102 super.
Ja, und dann habe ich im letzten Blutbild noch geguckt und festgestellt, ja, okay, aber Langzeitblutzucker, der ist auch super, der ist voll im Normbereich und alles.
ja, aber es ist halt so, muss ich
mal vorstellen, ne, ich hab dann teilweise
nachts um zwei echt so
bin ich mal aufgestanden, hab mein Blutbild rausgesucht
weil ich mir so Gedanken drüber gemacht hab
das ist wirklich
sehr weird champ, aber das Gute
ist
ähm
das Gute ist, man
kann das behandeln und
mir geht's jetzt auch schon viel besser
ich hab das die ganze Zeit
versucht, nur mit Therapie zu behandeln?
Wie kommst du überhaupt an ein Blutbild?
Ich lass mir einfach eine Kopie machen.
Obwohl, ist doch kein Ding.
Außerdem hab ich eine App, wo der Arzt das hochlädt.
Hm.
Was wollte ich jetzt
gerade sagen? Chat.
Das hab ich auch manchmal. Ich hab echt teilweise echt
Konzentrationsprobleme. Achso, genau.
Ich hab das eine Weile probiert,
nur mit Therapie, mit Psychotherapie
zu therapieren.
Das hat's aber alleine nicht
so richtig gebracht. Es war besser,
es war besser, aber ich hatte immer noch
teilweise tagelang so
krasse Durchhänger, wo ich mir super
viel Gedanken gemacht habe, mich reingesteigert habe
in irgendwas Bescheuertes, von dem ich eigentlich
wusste, dass es super, super dämlich
ist.
Kriegt das digital, ja.
So, und
jetzt seit
Anfang August, also das ging
fast, na nicht wirklich ein Jahr,
aber ein Dreivierteljahr ging das jetzt, ja.
Also quasi von Oktober, November bis
bis anfang august da bin ich da war ich noch mal bei meiner hausärztin und die hat gesagt zu mir
gehen sie mal jetzt klingt halt so klingt halt super krass aber die hat mir das erklärt die
hat gesagt gehen sie doch mal nach frankfurt in die psychiatrische ambulanz weil da können
die auch viel mehr zu Medikamenten und allem
Möglichen sagen. Die hat mir zwar schon was aufgeschrieben,
das hab ich dann schon ein, zwei Tage genommen, aber die hat gesagt,
ey, gehen Sie da doch mal hin.
Ähm,
und ich wollte nicht.
Ich wollte nicht, das liegt aber zum größten
Teil daran, weil, Leute,
man kennt das ja nur aus dem Fernsehen
oder was man so liest im Internet und so, da will man
da natürlich nicht hin, weil man ja sonst was denkt.
Damit denkt man, da wirst du gleich ans Bett gekettet und
kommst nie wieder raus oder sowas.
So.
Und
ein bisschen, ein bisschen billig
das, ja, ist jetzt,
das wusste ich aber auch nicht, das ist mir
auch jetzt erst aufgefallen, seit
dieser ganzen Geschichte, ja, so
und nachdem es dann mal wieder so richtig beschissen
war für 1, 2, 3 Tage
und ich dann auch gleichzeitig wieder,
das kommt ja alles so ein bisschen vom
Gleichen, so richtig Probleme hatte zu
schlafen, habe ich dann eines Morgens gesagt,
Max, du setzt dich jetzt ins Auto
und fährst da hin
und dann bin ich morgens
um 8 oder kurz vor 8 bin ich da rein und macht machen die auf bin ich da rein und
wenn er in die in die psychiatrie in die ambulanz habe gesagt ich krieg das einmal
auf die reihe und das kannst kannst doch jetzt auf dauer auch nicht sein kann er
sein dass es und die haben dann gesagt okay haben da noch etwas zu erzählen die
haben auch gesagt weil ich habe auch also ich habe den halt erzählt ich mache
mit Gedanken, dass es gar nicht mehr weggeht oder sowas
und die meinten dann halt so, hier
Herr Max, Sie müssen sich da echt keine Gedanken machen.
Ich arbeite hier schon seit 15
Jahren und kenne ganz viele
Leute, die sowas haben. Bis zu 20%
aller Menschen bekommen das mal
im Laufe ihres Lebens sowas in der Richtung und ich
habe noch keinen gesehen, wo es nicht wieder weggegangen
ist und sie schreibt mir jetzt
ein paar Pillen auf, die genau dafür sind.
So.
Und ich nehme jetzt einmal am Tag
Pillen dagegen
und abends zum Schlafen gehen noch
wenn ich
zu aufgeregt bin, noch was zum Schlafen
gehen. Ich wollte die ganze
Zeit ja auch keine Pillen nehmen, weil ich
übelst Schiss hatte, dass die abhängig machen oder so.
Aber das sind Pillen, die definitiv nicht abhängig
machen und das ist eigentlich kein Problem und das ist
was, was es schon ewig gibt und gut verträglich ist.
Deswegen mache ich mir jetzt da auch keine
Gedanken und ich muss echt sagen,
seitdem ich den Kram nehme,
geht es mir besser. Das hat es natürlich zwei
Wochen gedauert.
Die Pillen hast du
einem halben jahr wieder abgesetzt warum ach so ja gut die haben gesagt ich soll
es erst mal ein halbes jahr nehmen und wenn in einem halben jahr guten wieder
gut ist brauche ich dir nicht mehr
ja was soll ich abwarten du meinst dass wir wieder besser geht
dann
naja zumindest ich hatte am anfang ein bisschen nebenwirkungen aber das ging dann eigentlich ganz
gut
ja
Ja.
Äh, ne.
Ich, äh, Sertralin nehme ich.
Das ist aber alles ähnlich.
Das ist alles ähnlich.
Die ganzen Pillen, das ist alles ähnlich.
Äh, und übrigens.
Ich glaube, dir wird's super gehen.
Ach so meinst du das?
Ach, jetzt hab ich's verstanden.
Du meinst, weil ich die dann nicht mehr brauche, weil es mir dann gut gehen wird.
Ja, das ist nett von dir.
Ja, bist richtig.
Was meinst du, die Nebenwirkungen?
Ich war die erste, ich war die ersten paar Tage, war es mir so ein bisschen, war ich so ein bisschen...
Wieso, was ist? Ist doch alles gut.
war ich so ein bisschen
benommen und
danach ging es aber eigentlich.
Also ich habe da keine
großen Probleme mit.
In wie vielen Jahren hast du eigentlich
deine Ausbildung angefangen?
Boah.
25 oder so?
Was? Nee, warum?
Warum sollte man Angst vor den Pillen haben?
Ich habe mich sogar gefreut, dass ich Pillen gekriegt habe, weil das was ist, wo ich mir gedacht habe, ey, das hilft jetzt was.
Ja, viele machen ja mit 17
Ausbildung. Ich habe ja
davor was anderes gemacht.
Da rede ich ja nicht viel drüber.
Ich habe ja mal versucht, was
BWL-mäßiges zu machen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was
mich auf diesen Trichter gebracht hat.
Ich kann das heute nicht mal nachvollziehen.
Ne, ne, ich hab nicht...
Ne, ne, ne, ich hab kein BWL studiert.
Ne, ne.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Das ist für viele Leute schwierig, darüber zu reden.
Das ist übrigens fatal, wenn Ärzte so Sachen anfangen mit
stellen sie sich mal nicht so an und sowas.
Ach nee, du dachtest das.
Du dachtest das.
Ja.
Ja, es war nicht so.
Es gibt Ärzte, die reagieren so,
aber hofft mal
nicht, dass man so eingerät.
Ja.
Und ganz ehrlich,
du bist bei weitem nicht der Einzige.
Wie gesagt, die eine hat mir erzählt
dort in der Ambulanz,
dass bis zu 20% der Leute
sowas bekommen.
Im Lauf ihres Lebens.
Oh, jetzt geht's.
Jetzt kommen hier die Medikamenten-Tipps.
Moment, was?
Hallo aus dem Log.
Ich sage ja nicht so viel über die Medis, aber...
Und sie nicht zu verharmlosen.
Naja.
Ich nehme die ja auch nicht einfach just for fun.
Ja.
Ich nehme die auch nicht, weil ich da denke,
ich habe da mal Bock drauf, ja.
deswegen ist es schon sinnvoll
nicht ein
man kann die Sachen ja auch gar nicht random nehmen
du bekommst die Pillen ja auch normalerweise gar nicht
genau, deswegen kriegst du die auch nur
verschrieben
und da kann man denke ich ein bisschen
vertrauen, wenn man da einen gescheiten Arzt hat
schon haben
es hört sich wie Smarties an
Na ja.
Schmecken eklig.
Schmecken nicht wie Spatis.
Also ich
weiß jetzt nicht, Chat,
ob es irgendwie so rübergekommen ist.
So wie ich das erzählt habe,
sollte sich mal jeder irgendwelche
Tabletten einschmeißen, aber ehrlich gesagt
kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen, dass das so rübergekommen ist.
Ja, also
würde mich jetzt auch wundern.
Ich habe ja auch erzählt,
weshalb, warum?
Ja.
Aber so sieht's aus.
So, eigentlich wollte ich ja gar nicht so viel dazu erzählen.
Ja.
Ich krieg, ich krieg, ähm...
So Sachen vom Arzt krieg ich,
krieg ich digital.
Max, du bist lustig.
Wie jetzt?
Weil ich, weil ich versuche,
das mit Humor zu nehmen, oder wie?
Man muss so was
mit Humor
nehmen.
Oder zumindest versuchen, so mit der Zeit.
Weil ansonsten sitzt man echt nur noch da
und macht sich Gedanken.
Das ist blöde.
Ja, ich kann es glücklicherweise zum Teil
mittlerweile auch mit Humor nehmen.
Glaubst du an Geister und Dämonen?
Nee. Wie kommst du denn da drauf?
Null glaube ich da dran.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Diablos Season.
So, gut.
Genug über irgendwelche
Erkrankungssachen und so
geredet.
Mach das.
Gut, dann
habe ich eigentlich Updates fertig...
Ja, ich habe Updates fertig gemacht.
So, Chat, ähm...
Lass mal gucken. Können wir uns irgendwas anschauen hier?
Wie lange bist du eigentlich schon in der IT?
Boah, äh...
Zeit?
Das war knapp 20 Jahre.
Nicht ganz 20 Jahre.
Der neue Cosmic Desktop.
Der interessiert mich nicht.
Wie alt ich bin?
Ich bin 41.
Das glauben immer viele nicht.
Hast du jetzt schon...
Du meinst Omachi?
Ja.
Das hab...
Also in Videos hab ich mir das angeschaut.
Das hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Wir können...
Ich mach das mal auf hier.
Ich wollte das tatsächlich in irgendeinem Stream sogar mal ausprobieren.
Ja.
Ich bin...
Alter Sack.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Deine Sprache hält dich jung.
Ja, ich bin wahrscheinlich der einzige 41-Jährige, der in Twitch-Emojis redet.
Ich hab letztens...
Muss ich jetzt gerade nochmal erzählen, ne?
Weil ich ja was erzählt habe hier von Therapeut und sonst was.
Ich hab tatsächlich letztens...
Zu meinem Therapeut gesagt...
Nee, nee, kek L.
Ojojoj.
Was ist denn hier los?
Gifte, Killerkarnickel hat Subs gegiftet.
Dankeschön.
Massive, 5 Millionen Subs.
Pog.
Bro ist 41, benutzt Omega-Lull.
Was? Ich sag eher kek W.
Wer hat denn Glück gehabt?
Ah, Moment. Valorant hat auch noch gegiftet hier.
valorant nice dankeschön für den sub
und noch ein sub dankeschön leute ist richtig hier gönnerhaft heute er hat
alles was gekriegt akurai ich vermute mal nico film bot max mixon edrics
biking bavaria scheiterhaufen aus money
Danke schön, Leute, für die Subs.
Hat der anständig...
Nein, der hat es nicht gehört.
Da hatten wir gerade...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich Probleme mit meinem WLAN hatte.
Oder sonst was.
Ach so, ich mache das online.
Per Videokonferenz.
Und...
Da hatten wir gerade Verbindungsprobleme.
und das ist mir auch ganz recht ich will nicht unbedingt dass er hört dass ich sage
das ist mir so rausgerutscht das habe ich nicht beabsichtigt gemacht wie laut seine aktuelle
berufsbezeichnung ich bin senior linux engineer aber bald bin ich senior site reliability engineer
ich bin alt genug für senior 41
man sollte sich im besten fall mit linux auskennen wie viel verdienst du eigentlich
eigentlich? Ich habe dazu ein Video gemacht.
Auf YouTube.
Äh.
Das ist das alte.
Boah, habe ich denn das Video,
habe ich da nicht sogar schon ein Video zu gemacht?
Ich arbeite nicht in der Bank.
Ich habe in der Bank gearbeitet, jetzt arbeite ich bei einer Versicherung.
Bestehe ich die Probezeit nicht?
Kann das sein, dass ich da noch gar kein Update zugemacht habe?
Doch hier, da, das Video.
Vor zwei Jahren.
Da erzähle ich das.
ich kann es dir nicht in absoluten zahlen sagen weil also ich bin mir selbst nicht ganz sicher
aber ich arbeite ja auch noch vier tage die woche deswegen ist das für die meisten leute
natürlich nicht repräsentativ genau und also mit mit rufbereitschaft mit bonus
warte mal wie werden das eigentlich bei 100% egal ich sage euch einfach was mein kollege
verdient hat letztes jahr von dem weiß ich dass der hat exakt den gleichen job wie ich und verdient
auch mehr oder weniger exakt das gleiche und der man auch rufbereitschaft arbeit aber 100% so und
Und der hat richtig krass Rufbereitschaft gecrindet letztes Jahr.
Der hat fast 125k verdient.
Brutto.
Ich crine nicht so hart die Rufbereitschaft.
Bei mir wären es bei 100% wahrscheinlich...
115k oder sowas.
Vermutlich bei 100%.
Was ich noch nicht eingerechnet habe ist, dass es dieses Jahr ein bisschen mehr Geld noch gegeben hat.
Also, ja.
Aber so in dem Dreh.
so in dem Dreh ungefähr.
So irgendwie so
115k würde ich sagen.
Wenn man nicht so hart
die Rufbereitschaft grindet und wenn man 100%
arbeiten würde. Aktuell mache ich
eh nicht viel Rufbereitschaft.
Weil ich immer noch ab und zu
Probleme habe mit Schlafen.
Und
ich arbeite ja auch nur 4 Tage Woche.
Viel Spaß beim Schlafen.
Ich freue mich jedes Mal richtig,
wenn ich Steuern bezahlen muss.
Gibt kaum was geileres, ja.
Kann ordentlich steuern.
Was bedeutet
eine IT-Rufbereitschaft?
Du meinst
Rufbereitschaft, oder?
Muss man dann antanzen in der Firma und Sauer fixen,
oder was? Musst du mal...
Potenziell
sowas in der Rufbereitschaft,
ja, bei uns ist es nicht so.
Also,
zu meiner zeit wo ich noch beim internet provider gearbeitet habe da hatten wir
auch bereitschaft und da war das wirklich so was im zweifelsfall da war das wirklich
du musst zweifelsfall wenn da irgendwas wirklich großartig ausgefallen ist mit
hardware defekt und man kriegt das remote nicht gebacken hätte nachts
nach frankfurt ins rechenzentrum fahren müssen das wäre da so gewesen
Ja.
Aber jetzt...
Jetzt sieht das mit der Rufbereitschaft eher so aus, dass wir Services haben, für die unser Team verantwortlich ist.
und wir haben zwar immer einen oder eins bis zwei Leute,
die sich mit einem Service besonders gut auskennen
und auch explizit für diesen Service verantwortlich sind,
aber das geht natürlich nicht,
dass für jeden Service der Typ,
der auch richtig Ahnung davon hat,
immer Rufbereitschaft macht.
Dann hätten wir ja quasi das ganze Team
immer 24-7 in Rufbereitschaft.
Und deswegen machen wir einer pro Team
macht Rufbereitschaft nachts zum Beispiel
für alle Services, die wir im Team haben.
Das heißt aber auch, und das nimmt man aber auch in Kauf,
dass man halt im Zweifelsfall nicht super krasse Ahnung davon hat.
Wenn es wirklich was Kompliziertes ist,
müsstest du potenziell nachts deinen Chef rausklingeln,
der dann versucht, jemanden rauszuklingeln, der Ahnung hat.
Ist mir aber noch nicht passiert.
Wir haben ein paar Services, die sind nicht so wichtig,
dass es nachts Alerts gibt.
Och, mal wieder abgekackt hier, YouTuber.
irgendwie ist es lauter geworden wie kann das sein wie kann das sein dass es lauter geworden ist
das verstehe ich nicht wie viele tabs wahrscheinlich 150 oder so ja deswegen
macht einer rufbereitschaft für das für das ganze team so wir haben ein paar services die
sind nicht so wichtig dass es nachts alerts gibt die kann man sich dann morgens angucken wir haben
aber auch ein paar services die sind so wichtig dass es nachts alerts gibt meistens ist es so
dass man nachts nicht von irgendwie einem anwender ähnlich dass man nicht von irgendjemand der was
mit der anwendung direkt zu tun hat angerufen wird sondern meistens bekommt man nachts also
zu 95% ist es nachts, was einen weckt.
Irgendeine Monitoring,
irgendein Monitoring Alert.
Ja, von CheckMK.
Du hast aufgepasst.
Habe ich, glaube ich, schon mal erzählt.
Ich mag CheckMK nicht, aber
ich muss mich da mit CheckMK manchmal rumschlagen.
Muss man dann nachts wach bleiben
oder wird man wach geklingelt? Du wirst wach geklingelt.
Du wirst wach geklingelt.
Dann klingelt dein Handy.
so eine Alerting App ist das
dann klingelt dein Handy
wenn du da dran gehst, liest dir das Handy auch gleich
schon vor, wie der Alert heißt
so Text to Speech
so in System XY
Critical Fehlermeldung
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
da kannst du meistens beim Hören, weißt du schon ungefähr was Sache ist
und dann
stehst du nachts, keine Ahnung, um 3 Uhr auf
und
fährst den Rechner hoch
loggst dich Remote ein
und guckst, was Sache ist.
Meistens ist es nichts Großes.
Also bei mir war es
bisher nie was Größeres, wenn was
nachts kaputt ist.
Tja.
Aber nachdem
jeder Rufbereitschaft bei uns macht, hat jeder
auch ein gewisses Interesse dran, dass nicht zu viel
Shit alarmiert wird.
Also man muss sagen, es kommt nicht
oft vor.
Ja, also Wände...
Boah, es ist schwierig zu sagen.
Mal wirst du gefühlt jede Woche angerufen
und mal wirst du ein halbes Jahr gar nicht angerufen.
Ja.
Ich hab mal nachts
versucht, also
ich hab nen Alert gekriegt,
wollte mich einloggen
und dann ging der
Remote Zugang nicht.
Da habe ich schon ein bisschen Panik gekriegt
und im Endeffekt
kam dann raus,
ich habe mich das erste Mal
vertippt bei meinem Passwort,
wahrscheinlich,
da habe ich voll Panik gekriegt,
weil ich mir gedacht habe, fuck, warum geht Remote nicht
und habe dann noch zweimal das falsche Passwort
eingegeben, weil ich mich so aufgeregt habe, weil ich gedacht habe,
Mist, was ist jetzt los? Und dann habe ich
mich für fünf Minuten ausgesperrt.
Das ist, glaube ich, so ziemlich der ungünstige
Zeitpunkt, sich selbst auszusperren.
Wenn du nachts
eigentlich was nachgucken musst.
X-Fatal, danke schön für den Sub.
Wieso macht man eigentlich noch so viel mit Passwort?
Ich hoffe, weil es der am akzeptiertesten, kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner ist.
Es ist aber bei uns ja nicht nur Passwort, muss man dazu sagen.
Wir haben ja noch mehrere Faktoren, die man braucht, um sich Remote einloggen zu können.
Also rein mit Passwort kommst du nicht weiter.
Du brauchst Username, du brauchst Passwort und dann brauchst du noch mehrere weitere Faktoren, die du besitzen musst, um dich einloggen zu können.
Link mal Passwort 123456.
Aber was kann man sich unter einem Service vorstellen, den ihr nachts fixen müsst?
Also, es gibt grundsätzlich zwei verschiedene Arten von Services, die gefixt werden müssen, wenn sie nachts kaputt gehen.
Es gibt einmal Services, da läuft morgens direkt zum Start irgendwas ganz Wichtiges drauf.
Also müsst ihr euch vorstellen, um 7 Uhr passiert mit dem Service schon irgendwas, wo richtig viel Geld dran hängt.
Dann willst du natürlich nicht, dass du irgendwie um 7.30 Uhr erst merkst, dass das Ding nicht geht.
Das wird dann auch nachts um 3 Uhr gefixt, obwohl nachts um 3 Uhr selbst gar nichts läuft.
Aber du willst dann 100% sicher sein, dass das Ding um 7 Uhr funktioniert.
Das ist das Erste.
Dann gibt es Services, die machen auch tatsächlich nachts was.
Und dafür ist es wichtig, dass die zur Verfügung stehen.
Weil egal, ob es jetzt eine Versicherung ist, wie bei mir, oder eine Bank, das sind ja meistens große Unternehmen, die international arbeiten, die haben dann auch unterschiedliche Verstrickungen mit anderen Ländern, wo das dann halt vielleicht mittags ist, wenn es bei uns nachts um drei ist.
Und da gibt es Systeme, die müssen funktionieren. Und dann musst du die auch nachts um drei fixen.
Und dann gibt es noch eine dritte, fällt mir gerade noch ein, gibt es noch eine dritte
Sorte von System.
Das ist ein System, was selbst eigentlich nicht wichtig ist, um irgendwas bereit zu
stellen, aber das ist, nennen wir es mal ein Support System.
Also Support Services, nenne ich das jetzt mal.
Also zum Beispiel für Datenübertragung, wo dann wiederum heißt, okay, wenn das Ding
nicht geht, verliert man nicht unmittelbar Geld,
aber dadurch sind
ganz viele anderen Services extrem
betroffen, wenn Datenübertragung oder
Datenaustausch zwischen Services nicht mehr funktioniert.
Deswegen muss der Datenübertragung
Service funktionieren und auch nach zum 3.
War das verständlich?
Käsekuchen.
Microsoft, ey, ich hasse diese App.
richtig freudige app
wir haben halt nur best bis business high ac business enterprise best
practices das muss an java liegen glaube ich jetzt mal wieder zeit für eine
arbeit gab 0 wird es nicht wie zufrieden bist du aktuell ich bin sehr zufrieden
und mein chef hat auch plan vom von business von dem was wir machen ja also
ich könnte arbeitstechnisch eigentlich gerade nicht zufriedener sein
ich habe auch weniger bekommen als das in der ausbildung aber wie gesagt meine
ausbildung ist schon eine ganze weile her da war das war das noch anders aber
heute da kostet alles mehr habe ich glaube ich nur einmal irgendwie doch
gestartet das ist dieses task das ist so ein bisschen so ein bisschen wie da
kannst du verschiedene service miteinander verbinden wie heißt das wie
heißt die die oft so was wie wie oft ist das ist werden wird jetzt unseren
tool wurde verschiedene service miteinander verketten kannst ich glaube
sowas ist das ich glaube ich glaube bei uns auf der arbeit ich glaube da vibe
coded kein einziger java entwickler wie repariert ihr die services was geht
kaputt es ist ganz unterschiedlich der klassiker ist vollgelaufene festplatte
das kommt in besten kreisen vor vollgelaufene festplatte ist gar nicht
mal so selten meistens ist die festplatte nicht wirklich voll sondern
es gibt ein alert weil 90 prozent voll weil irgendwas da amok läuft und log
files rausdammt noch und nöcher also festplatten platz ist schon klassiker
kommt auf das vor dann gibt es abgeschmierte services da sagt dann system d das ding ist
nicht nicht healthy oder wie auch immer das bei system d heißt das check des monitor gesagt hier
service ist gecrasht dann gibt es noch eine meldung wenn irgendwas schlimmes in dem logg
fall drin steht die sind glücklicherweise zum größten teil ganz gut diese filter für die lok
files also die filtern wie gesagt zu 90 prozent wirklich nur das was wirklich sehr kritisch ist
ja zum beispiel service a kann nicht mehr zu seiner datenbank connecten oder irgendwie sowas
und so dinge ja also wirst du dann benachrichtigt und wie das repariert wird ja gut das hängt
natürlich davon ab was was eigentlich wirklich kaputt ist wenn der dienst gecrasht ist relativ
easy die zwei staaten wenn die festplatte voll ist sehr klassiker tippmann paar log files dann
geht es bestimmt wieder es ist auch immer nur hot hot gefixe nachts ja also ich glaube keiner von
uns macht wirklich das so ordentlich wie geht nachts also ich gehe dann auch nur
den lockt verzeichnet gegen geht's immer mal alles dann gucke ich df minus hr wir
sind wieder unter 90 prozent okay ich gehe wieder pennen wenn ich ganz gut
drauf bin schreibe ich in das incident ticket noch rein wurde aufgeräumt macht
es zu
Nachts nur Quick & Dirty, Klassiker.
Ah ja.
Wer hat nachts, guck mal,
hättet ihr Bock darauf,
nachts eine Viertelstunde schnell was zu fixen
oder eine Stunde da zu sitzen?
Wenn ihr eine Stunde da gesessen habt,
seid auf jeden Fall richtig wach
und könnt wahrscheinlich für zwei Stunden danach nicht mehr pennen.
Ja, aber ich denke, Frage beantwortet, oder?
Schaut dein Chef noch deine Videos?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Also, die nicht vorhandenen Videos, ja.
Aber mein neuer Chef weiß, kennt meinen YouTube-Channel nicht.
Also, er weiß, dass ich einen habe, glaube ich,
aber der kennt kennt den channel nicht mein alter chef der hat die videos ab und zu geguckt
also fast 20 jahren habe ich die ausbildung gemacht ja wie gesagt
bin seit fast 20 jahren da it technisch am start
was müssen wir müssen best practice asymmetrische verifizierung verfahren
was was genommen oder sollte das ist bis das wüsste enterprise
du musst erst mal die low hanging fruits abgreifen
und erst mal feststellen ob ob du eine niet hast und dann definieren was der key zum success ist
Du meinst, wir sind 100.000 verschiedene Dinger?
Du meinst, warum wir 100.000 verschiedene Services haben, oder wie?
historisch gewachsen würde ich mal sagen
okay bin jetzt nicht so drin in der ita warum fallen solche sachen aus abgesehen
von einem hardware ausfall haben wir eigentlich so gut wie nie wenn ihr nicht
so programmiert dass sie nicht ausfallen naja keiner programmiert immer nur perfektes zeug
ist einfach so
Ist nicht alles perfekt?
Wenn alles perfekt wäre, würde nie was kaputt gehen.
Ja, ist es aber nicht.
Ja, bei uns ist natürlich alles immer fehlerfrei.
Ja.
Und dazu kommt, dass manchmal Sachen kaputt gehen, wo du nicht so richtig Einfluss als Anwendungsentwickler drauf hast.
ja zum beispiel wenn das netzwerk aus irgendwelchen gründen ruckelt wenn die
datenbank aus irgendwelchen gründen probleme hat wenn routing mäßig
irgendwas nicht geht wenn google irgendwelche komischen wartungsarbeiten
macht das irgendwelche kubernetes notes wegfliegen und danach der cluster so
halb funktionieren da hängt du steckst da nicht so wirklich drin was alles
passieren kann du kannst aber davon ausgehen wenn es
die möglichkeit zu gibt das was kaputt gehen kann dann wird es früher oder
doch später mal kaputt gehen
es gibt auch sagen ich habe gar nicht habe aktuelles beispiel es gibt auch
sachen da hast du überhaupt keinen einfluss drauf zum beispiel wir betreiben
ja bei uns block chain notes polygon polygon block channels habe ich ja schon mal hier im
stream erzählt und auch wir haben ja sogar mal was programmiert für für diese block chain software
die wir da verwenden und die machen öfters mal komische dinger ja die ford die block chain und
dann musste eine mindestversion von der software benutzen wenn das denn schnell genug machst dann
geht es nicht manchmal verschluckt sich das zeug auch und dann generiert irgendwie keine
neuen blöcke mehr also wenn du abhängig bist von so externen sachen auf die du keine einflüsse
hast kann trotzdem dann zeug kaputt gehen ja und gerade unser blog trend geht uns das läuft
nur so semi-stabil. Das liegt nicht an uns.
Vollgelaufene Festplatten sind der Klassiker.
Übrigens, ich sag immer Festplatte.
Ich meine damit nicht wirklich die klassische
Festplatte, ja? Also was da an Storage
unten drunter ist, ist komplett transparent für mich.
Der größte Teil davon dürfte
SSDs sein.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob wir überhaupt noch normale Platten
mittlerweile haben. Also das meiste sind
SSDs. Das ist halt irgendein Storage,
den du professioniert kriegst, auf welchem Storage,
also wo das unten drunter auf irgendeinem storage system rauskommt kein blass und schimmer
willst du eigentlich nicht auf die security seite wechseln warum bisschen security kram mache ich
ja auch aber so zu vollständig weiß nicht also erstens würde ich sagen so für vollständige
stelle vollständig kenne ich mich einfach nicht gut genug aus und weiß ich auch nicht ob ich da
so richtig bock drauf hätte
Wie würdest du am liebsten Logging unter .NET implementieren?
Würdest du das iLogin...
Okay, also.
Mir fehlen natürlich die Business Enterprise Erfahrungen, was .NET angeht.
Ich war noch nie in irgendeinem großen Team, was irgendeine riesengroße Enterprise .NET Anwendung programmiert hat,
wo das vielleicht anders laufen würde, als das, was ich jetzt sage.
Aber für meine Sachen, ganz ehrlich, wahrscheinlich werden die meisten Leute mal sagen,
Max, wie kannst du sowas machen?
Ich weiß, dass es ein bisschen verpönt ist, was ich jetzt sage, aber ich finde Serilog nice und ich finde ein globales Console-Log eigentlich am besten.
Also scheiß auf iLogger.
einfach
Serilog, ich weiß gar nicht
wie das richtige
Kommando ist
einfach
raus auf die Konsole direkt
ohne irgendwelche Abstractions
Scheiß drauf
Serilog ist nice, weil da kannst du
so Sachen beispielsweise machen wie Structured Logging
kannst du dann am Ende
da kannst du schön in irgendeinen loch kollektor kollektor system das reinhauen kannst du einzelne
requests besser analysieren weil halt kontext informationen dazu hast so von wo wohin welche
funktion wurde aufgerufen aber auch für ganz normale ausgabe auf die kommandozeile mit
timestamp und sonst wieder busen dabei setzt ein standardformat und dann haus einfach auf
die konsole raus ich benutze ganze logger krempel so gut wie nie
ich kann es aber verstehen wenn jemand sagt er hat sie eine richtig große
business enterprise anwendungen und will sie diese standard logging interface
verwenden ja mach
Mario, bist du zufrieden mit der Antwort?
Wahrscheinlich nicht das, was du hören willst.
In Rufbereitschaft erst mal einen Test schreiben,
damit das nicht hier passiert.
Und erst dann fliegen... Ja, klar.
Ja, ich glaube, das macht fast jeder.
Aber selbst wenn du nach Stunden bezahlt wirst, hast du keinen Bock nachts.
Also bei uns, guck mal, Alfred, du darfst nicht vergessen, du wirst ja auch bezahlt für Rufbereitschaft.
Und wenn du Einsatz hast, dann kriegst du echte Arbeitszeit gut geschrieben und kriegst die bezahlt.
Okay, das mag vielleicht ein bisschen mehr sein
Aber nicht so sehr, dass es sich lohnt
Anstatt eine Viertelstunde, zwei Stunden nachts um drei
Darum zu hocken
Ich muss ehrlich sagen
Jetzt wo ich mir das gerade durchlese
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das stimmt, was ich sage
Vielleicht ist es doch so viel mehr, dass es sich lohnt
müsste ich mir mal überlegen
wir bekommen die ganze nacht bezahlt deswegen ist bei uns auch wochenend
rufbereitschaft sehr beliebt also wochenend rufbereitschaft bei uns ist
von freitagabend bis montagmorgen das sind dann quasi boah was sind das
irgendwie 60 stunden oder so ja doch irgendwie so sei ich sage jetzt einfach
mal 60 stunden oder so was sind das ja dann und dass das bringt bei uns bringt
das fast nicht ganz abbringt fast 1000 euro
pepo burn money
das schon ordentlich wie ich wach werde mein handy alarmiert mich
oweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweowe
Wochen höchst Arbeitszeit.
Was? Weiß ich nicht, was du meinst.
Ich bin aber ein Fan von der 4-Tage-Woche.
Also ich fände es nice, wenn wir generell eine 4-Tage-Woche hätten.
Und ich meine damit nicht, arbeite dafür 10 Stunden am Tag und dafür kriegst du einen Tag frei,
sondern wirklich 8 Stunden am Tag und dafür nur 4 Tage.
80 plus ist Requirement.
Steht so im Jammer-File.
Vielleicht haben die schlechte Erfahrung bei euch gemacht, dass die Leute irgendwie ewig brauchen, ihre alte Hardware zurückzugeben.
Max Interesse an Security hat nach 8 Zeichen den Passwort auf.
Ja, so ist es.
Manchmal mache ich auch 9 Zeichen, wenn es Mindestlänge ist.
Internes DNS, Monkess.
Ich benutze das DNS von meinem MikroTik-Router.
Da kann man nicht viel dran machen.
wobei könnte man schon aber mache ich nicht und er geht einfach seit jahren schon aktuelle
verfahren für user aus flächen deutsch besser gelöst werden kann aus also für dort nett kann
ich sagen was bei asp.net die könnten user authentifizierung auf jeden fall besser lösen
fällt mir doch gerade ein, auch wenn es vielleicht nicht das ist,
was du meinst, weil das super verwirrend
ist, wie sie das eingebaut
haben.
Max, was würdest du heute anders
machen, wenn du von Anfang an neu starten würdest?
Ähm,
ich würde
mit der
Auszubildenden ins Hotelzimmer mitgehen.
Bei der
Weihnachtsfeier.
Und mich nicht so doof anstellen,
wie ich es gemacht habe.
Aber du meinst natürlich, was rein beruflich ist.
Was würde ich heute anders machen?
Gibt es da eine Story zu?
Ja, gibt es ein Video zu, glaube ich.
Oder gab es ein Video zu?
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Als ich auch die Ausbildung gemacht habe,
habe ich mich mit einer Mitauszubildenden ziemlich gut verstanden.
und wir haben uns da immer so ein bisschen angeguckt,
ein bisschen Späßchen gemacht und alles so, ja.
Also ich würde sagen, so die Chemie hat gestimmt
und sie hat mich dann bei der Weihnachtsfeier gefragt,
ob ich sie quasi, ob wir nicht ein bisschen früher gehen wollen
und ich sie noch zum Zug bringen kann.
So und...
Ja, ich hab's halt, lange Rede kurz, ich hab's halt verkackt.
ich hab's halt verkackt ich hab's nicht gecheckt ich hab's nicht gecheckt und
bin dann bin da nicht mehr zum ja egal
haben noch gezockt bisschen das war ich war nicht daheim das war eine andere
stadt da wo die zentrale von meinem ausbildungsbetrieb war
ich habe es nicht kapiert oder besser nicht schnell genug geschaltet und ich
Ich mochte die wirklich.
Ja, egal.
Da kann ich mir jetzt gar nicht so viele Gedanken drüber machen.
Gibt es einen guten Grund,
ein selbstgebautes Logging-Framework zu nehmen,
anstatt eines, welches sie etabliert hatten,
schon jahrelang auf dem Markt?
Das sind sie eigentlich nicht.
Ja genau, außer man findet sich sehr geil.
Ob wir was extra bekommen?
Ja, es ist so, wir bekommen...
Wir bekommen halt ganz ordentlich Kohle fürs Nixmachen bei der Rufbereitschaft.
Aber wenn wir Einsatz haben, dann bekommen wir in der Zeit Arbeitszeit.
Gut geschrieben.
Und eventuell auch irgendeinen Bonus, wenn es nachts ist.
Ich weiß es jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Ich habe mir die letzten Rufbereitschaft-Einsätze nie aufgeschrieben.
Ich habe einfach das Geld von der Bereitschaft genommen und für die Viertelstunde, 20 Minuten, wo ich was gemacht habe,
die paar Euro kommt es mir nicht an.
Ich war zu faul, das aufzuschreiben.
Ne, das ist nur die Pauschale.
Deswegen war ich zu faul, das überhaupt aufzuschreiben.
Ja, bei 20 Minuten Einsatz hätte ich dann vielleicht am Ende irgendwie noch 30 Euro mehr gekriegt oder sowas.
Der Portal-Modus sieht deutlich besser aus als der von Battlefield 2042.
Singleplayer-Story habe ich noch fast nichts zu gesehen.
neuen plänen acht stunden tag abzuschaffen da habe ich nichts da habe ich noch gar nichts
von gehört als soll die leute jetzt noch mehr schaffen letztens war doch noch vier tage woche
für alle irgendwie mal im gespräch die theorie besagt in vier tagen mehr schaffen als in fünf
begründung höhere produktivität durch das längere auskriegen also ich gehe
davon aus dass es tatsächlich so ist dass nicht viel unterschied gibt
produktivität weil man mal ehrlich die meisten leute von den acht stunden
gerade dort wo büro pflicht ist die meisten leute machen doch von den acht
stunden wenn es hoch kommt zwei stunden wirklich konzentriert intensiv irgendwas
der rest ist wir mieten uns ein ab wir gehen an kaffeeautomat wir gehen was
mittagessen irgendeiner kommt zu dir an platz und schwätzt dich an du gehst zu
einem hin und und guckst irgendwas die dich labert einer im gang an
es rufen leute an die irgendwie random sinnlose sachen wollen
ja und wenn man da ein bisschen mehr struktur reinbringen würde muss ich auch von arbeitgeber
seite ein bisschen mit organisiert werden könnte bestimmten vier tagen so viel schaffen wie in 5
also ich bin im home office 100 prozent produktiver als auf der arbeit also der
Tag, wo ich in Frankfurt bin,
an dem Tag mache ich fast nichts.
Das liegt aber
nicht daran, weil ich mich hinsetze und sage,
ich will nichts machen, sondern weil an dem Tag
von morgens bis abends durchgängig
gemietet wird.
Erst haben wir so Neuigkeiten
aus der Abteilungsmiete. Moment, warte.
Ich kann euch das mal sagen.
Passt mal auf.
Oh, mir fällt gerade ein, ich habe auf der Arbeit noch ein Backup-Restore laufen.
Und ich habe um...
Ich habe um...
Ups.
Ich habe um 17.30 Uhr geschrieben.
Ich loge mich gleich noch mal ein und gucke, ob es fertig ist.
Moment, was haben wir jetzt? 20.10 Uhr?
Ups.
Ich hab vorher tatsächlich schon mal reingeguckt
Da war es noch nicht fertig
Ja
Ich guck nach dem Stream rein
So, aber
Was ich jetzt eigentlich gucken wollte, pass mal auf
Mittwochs, okay, Moment, ich muss mal runterscrollen
Okay
Mittwochs geht's los mit
So Berichten
Neues aus der Abteilung
So
Dann Daily Scrum
Vom Projekt
dann SureFix von einem Service, den wir betreuen, dann Support Meeting mit einem Hersteller, der für ein Software programmiert, dann Gruppen Meeting, dann weiteres Service Meeting für ein Service, den wir betreuen, dann Team Meeting
und dann noch hinten drauf
Austausch und
Synchschur fix
für ein Projekt, in dem ich mitmache.
So, so sieht mein Mittwoch aus.
Das erste
Gemiete geht los um 9
und
das letzte Gemiete ist fertig um 16 Uhr.
So sieht der Mittwoch aus.
Was soll ich da noch groß machen?
Ne, Winbox benutze ich nicht, ich benutze das Webinterface.
Winbox benutze ich nur, wenn das Webinterface rumspackt von meinem MikroTik-Router.
Das ist doch Kontakt zum M-Core. Boah, lange schon nicht mehr vom M-Core. Lange nichts mehr vom M-Core gehört. Nee.
Max, wollen wir das Fireship-Video zu... Okay, machen wir.
Machen wir.
das da
Max bist du noch Jungfrau?
haben wir im Stream schon mal coolify ausprobiert?
nee aber ich wollte auch ich wollte mal dog ploy ausprobieren nicht coolify
Webapplication 11 die zweite oder doch die elfte ich glaube mindestens die zweite elfte
die die die die ausgabe beim starten des übrigens auch toll von von dem von der
anwendung hier guck mal ich habe keine ahnung was es überhaupt macht beim starten aller zwei
und irgendwann geht's dann das treibt irgendwas ich habe echt keine ahnung was da programmiert
aber was funktioniert das ist die software mit der ich in diese bilder auf overlays mache
Irgendwas tritt hier
Ob wir gut essen gehen in Frankfurt?
Ich gehe in letzter Zeit gar nichts mehr warm Mittagessen, wenn ich in Frankfurt bin.
Da wird man immer so müde von.
Und ich hatte es jetzt schon ein paar Mal, dass ich beim Mittagessen,
ich kann es nicht so ganz festmachen, woran es liegt,
Dünnschiss gekriegt habe in irgendwelchen Frankfurter Restaurants.
und du hast echt keinen Bock auf der Arbeit mittags mit Dünnschiss zu hocken oder gar im Zug.
Im Zug ist es noch schlimmer.
Deswegen esse ich eigentlich nichts Warmes mehr in Frankfurt.
Ja.
Wie viele Meetings kann man mit einer E-Mail überflüssig machen?
Ich würde sagen, gar nicht mal so viele bei uns.
Weil das meistens irgendwelche regelmäßigen
Wir-tauschen-uns-zu-Service-XY-aus sind.
Wo dann von zig Abteilungen Leute dabei sind und sowas.
Teilweise auch unternehmensübergreifend.
Weiß ich nicht, wie gut man das mit einer einzelnen Mail machen könnte.
man könnte sicherlich doch du hast recht man könnte man könnte sicherlich
einiges abfackeln wenn man sich darauf verständigen würde dass die leute wenn
es themen gibt die besprochen werden müssen einfach die kurz vorher vorher
quasi sagen so anmelden so und wenn es keine themen gibt lässt man das meeting
ausfalten er ausfallen das wäre dann tatsächlich
ganz sinnvoll also nach dem motto man sammelt weil keine ahnung es gibt jede
woche irgendwie ein status meeting und man sammelt einfach die woche über und
wenn es bis zum Meeting startet oder bis bis keine Stunde bevor das startet noch keine
Tagesordnungspunkte gibt, lässt man es einfach ausfallen.
Ja, das wäre tatsächlich ganz sinnvoll.
Das können wir mit einer Mail überflüssig machen.
Wird aber nicht gemacht.
Ist so Battlefield 6 Stream wahrscheinlich schon.
Mal gucken, wie es mir gefällt.
Wie groß ist die Firma, in der du arbeitest?
Ich hoffe, mein Chef guckt nicht zu.
Er kennt den Namen ja von mir gar nicht.
Aber ich habe gar keine Ahnung, wie viele Mitarbeiter wir genau haben.
Es sind auf jeden Fall recht viele.
Also ich würde mal sagen über 1000.
Ja, muss über 1000 sein.
Die IT alleine hat ja schon nicht ganz so viel, aber einiges.
schauen das video jetzt sobald ich den chat durch habe wenn die sitze bei der db immer
räume kommt mir das nur so vor also mit den sitzen habe ich meistens wenig probleme obwohl
es ekligerweise in frankfurt welche gibt ihre nacken füße auf die zug sitze stellen das ist
immer ganz ganz toll aber ich habe ein foto gepostet auf twitter jetzt x aber dass mein
größtes problem mit der wahnsinnig die sitze
aber schon ich lasse ich direkt nach deiner ausbildung bekommt 33 1500 euro
im jahr aber das ist schon wie gesagt eine ganze
weile her und wir hatten es auch irgendwann mal hochgerechnet auf heute
Ich habe aber vergessen, was es heute gewesen wäre.
Irgendwie 45k oder sowas glaube ich.
Beste Loks.
3.0, 3.1.
Will bei euch auch die Führungsebene auf Power Automated?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Die Führungsebene möchte aber
Windows Defender für Linux einführen.
Stellt euch das mal vor.
Und wer sich jetzt fragt, das gibt's?
Ja, das gibt's.
Hatten wir beim letzten Arbeitgeber auch.
Das lief so gut, dass kurz bevor ich weg bin,
es wieder abgeschafft wurde.
Es gibt Windows Defender für Linux.
Michael, 50 Milliarden. Schön, dich wieder zu sehen.
Was, von Frankfurt oder?
Was? Nein.
Wir gehen immer von Frankfurt am Main.
Hättest du eigentlich was zu tun,
wenn du keine Meetings hättest?
Denn mir würde schon irgendwie was fehlen.
Mittlerweile habe ich mich so dran gewöhnt.
Ich habe mich auch daran gewöhnt, dass alles drei Tage dauert, weil so viel gemietet wird zwischendurch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich meinen Kopf wieder auf Tage ohne Meetings umschalten könnte.
Ist bei euch die Codequalität durch den Einsatz von AI schlechter geworden über die letzten zwei bis drei Jahre?
Also, ich kann es nicht beurteilen. Ich denke nicht.
Weil ich glaube, kein einziger Vibe codet da.
Ich wissen tue ich es nicht.
da wurde ich darauf einstellen muss ist aber der zug zu spät ist
ich denke schon dass ich dieses jahr noch ein video mache
instant aber ich glaube du erzählst uns hier mit einem
iq von 79 bist du gar nicht in der lage ob ein chat was zu schreiben
ich glaube das ist debate könnte das sein ich wollte einfach ich wollte gerade genau
das gleiche sagen ich wollte gerade genau das gleiche sagen du kannst aber
prime subscriben dann kriegst du einen IQ oben drauf
darfst du da bleiben so wir sind durch also das video soll ich mir angucken wo
das zuckerburg aufs maul gefallen ist sagt der chat gucken wir mal
Wir brauchen kein Donation Goal.
Ich muss mich immer um neue Emotes und Badges kümmern.
Guck mal, da ist ja schon 2,5 Jahre dabei und hat nur den Goldkeks.
Es gibt keine weiteren.
Ich habe aber...
Mein Problem ist ein bisschen, ich habe keine Ideen für weitere Badges.
Vielleicht fällt euch irgendwas ein?
Ach nee, das ist die 2,5 Jahre.
Du bist 62.
62 Monate, Alter.
What the fuck?
Jetzt sehe ich es ja erst.
Alter, bist du lange dabei.
Das ist nur die 2,5-Jahres-Badge.
62 Monate.
Das sind über 5 Jahre.
Dark Matter Keks.
Ja.
Da müssen wir was machen.
So, wenn ich jetzt auf Meeting wäre, würde ich sagen, wir nehmen das Thema mit.
Ihr wisst, was dann passiert, oder?
Da sind wir dran an dem Thema.
Aber du hast recht, wir brauchen unbedingt neue Badges und wir brauchen auch unbedingt neue Emotes.
Ja, das ist sowas von dem Scope.
Die Frage ist, wie viele T-Shirt-Größen das beansprucht.
Oh je.
Guck mal, ich hab dir schon einen Whip gegeben wahrscheinlich,
weil ich es irgendjemandem versprochen habe und nicht gemacht habe.
Ich kann dir nichts... Es gibt keinen Super-Whip.
Ich kann dir jetzt nichts anderes mehr geben.
Aber wie soll dann Dark Matter Keks aus?
Aber das muss ich mir mal aufschreiben.
Finde ich ist eine gute Idee.
Ich kann mich ja mal von irgendwelchen Call of Duty Waffenskins inspirieren lassen.
Da gibt es bestimmt noch mehr sinnlose Tarnungen.
Dragon Scale oder sowas gab es doch auch mal.
Dragon Scale Keks.
Ne, Krone geht nicht so gut, weil, guckt mal, Krone wird das ganze Seitenverhältnis wieder kaputt machen.
Wobei, doch, das würde funktionieren, das würde funktionieren, ähm, das würde funktionieren, wenn die Krone auf dem Kopf sitzt ein bisschen.
Aber gute Idee, Chat.
Ich schreib mir das mal auf.
Ich lasse kein KI nix generieren.
Jetzt lasse ich richtige Pixel, nein nicht wirklich Pixel, Emote Artists machen.
Ich habe es mir aufgeschrieben.
Chat, ich, passt mal auf.
Hier, guckt mal.
So schnell kann ich nicht tippen, Leute.
Das ist, was ich mir aufgeschrieben habe.
So schnell kann ich noch gar nicht tippen.
Morgen, KS.
Der Chat wieder.
Keck Alu auf dem Kopf.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns das Video, das, ähm, FireShip-Video an.
Gucken, ob's laut genug ist.
Okay.
Schnapper!
Ich habe letztens bei einer CT einen Test gelesen zu irgendeinem China-Chinesen-Smartglass
und die haben geschrieben, das ist ziemlich gut.
Was?
Okay.
Da habe ich ja auch Gerüchte zugehört, dass das beabsichtigt war.
Für mehr Schlagzeilen.
Oh mein Gott.
Vielleicht war das ein bisschen zu hart.
In diesem Video schauen wir uns die unglaubliche Technik hinter Metas neuen halbgebakten Ray-Bans an
und finden heraus, wie es sein wird, mit anderen Menschen in der Zukunft zu interagieren.
Es ist September 18, 2025.
Ich dachte, er zeigt wenigstens, wie er aufs Maul fliegt.
Und ihr schaut den Code-Report.
Als Meta ihre AI-Smartglasen letztes Jahr veröffentlichte,
wurde die erste Sache, die Leute gemacht haben, eine App für die Menschen in der Realzeit zu entwickeln,
Das hat die Welt natürlich unbedingt gebraucht.
Es geht wahrscheinlich aber auch alles direkt zu Facebook, oder?
Also alles, was du damit machst und scannst und OCRst und was nicht, ist wirklich direkt der Upload, zack, Facebook.
Sorry, Meta.
Natürlich, was sonst?
und es ermöglichen, Dinge zu machen, die nicht mal für einen Tag reichen.
Wie Konversationen in der Realzeit zu einer Sprache.
Sie können Bilder im echten Weltraum erkennen und auch mit neuen Bilder generieren.
Das ist ja geil! Das ist wichtig!
Sie können Bilder im echten Weltraum erkennen.
Das ist ganz furchtbar wichtig, dass es einem sagt, sie sehen gerade Tomaten.
Als wüssten sie nicht, was ich ohne machen soll.
... in der echten Welt ist und auch mit neuen Bildern, die von AI generiert werden.
Ein echterer Fall für diese Fähigkeit ist, dass es eine moderne Frau in eine Trad-Frau tun könnte,
indem sie sich aufleveln oder Küchenkünste.
Bei MetaConnect haben sie versucht, live zu demonstrieren, aber es hat hart verfehlt.
Was mache ich zuerst?
Du hast bereits die Basis-Ingrедиente kombiniert.
Also jetzt gräte ein Paar, um es zur Sauce zu geben.
Was mache ich zuerst?
Ja, muss natürlich ja WiFi liegen.
They tried to play it off as a WiFi problem, but clearly the problem is that the AI here just isn't very intelligent.
The third and most impressive innovation though is the Meta Neural Band, a wristband that comes with every pair of display glasses.
Es benutzt Elektromyographie-Technologie, um kleine elektrische Signale in deinen Rüsten zu bemerken, die zu der Art, wie du deine Hände bewegst, verfolgen.
Diese Technik kann tatsächlich detekten, wie deine Hände bewegen werden, bevor der Bewegungs-Event passiert.
Es verwendet komplett alte-Fashion-Touchscreens auf antiken Geräten wie dem iPhone,
weil alles jetzt mit subtilen Fingerbewegungen kontrolliert werden kann.
Das
Impressivste ist, dass es auf alle Menschen ohne Kalibration funktioniert, die einzige Erklärung ist, dass Menschen ohne Arme sind.
Das unglaubliche Feat wurde durch das Testen von über 200.000 Teilnehmern erreicht.
Aber ist diese Anwendung tatsächlich intuitiv aus der Perspektive von einem UX-Perspektive?
Ich weiß nicht über dich.
Wenn ich TV sehe...
Das ist mein Fehler.
Es ist alles gut.
Okay.
Heißt der Bonus ist gestrichen.
Wir sind gut.
Es ist wirklich live.
Wie man sieht, seemen auch Meta-Employee, die es nicht nutzen können.
Aber trotz dieser Live-Demo-Failures muss man Meta ein bisschen Kredit geben,
dass sie die Balls live demoen.
Es ist ein erheblicher Veränderung von den überglamourösen Apple-Style-Erkennungen.
Aber Meta könnte wahrscheinlich ein stabileres Produkt schicken,
wenn sie ihre CI-CD-Pipelines mit Blacksmith, dem Sponsor von heute,
der hingeflogen ist, aber
macht man anscheinend nicht.
Ja, sollen die mal machen.
Ganz ehrlich, mir könnte es kaum egaler
sein, was Meta da wieder treibt.
Er ist nur
sprichwörtlich hingeflogen. Achso.
ich dachte der ist wirklich aufs maul gefallen
das ist langweilig dachte der ist den hat es wirklich
sagt man ja was kann man sonst noch angucken
das will ich mir nicht angucken ich wollte dass ich so mal kurz zeigen was
voll abgedreht finde der kerl hat ein raid weil sie nicht 50 oder ich weiß gar nicht was es für
den raid ist mit oder oder 50 disketten irgendwie der alle diskret über disketten laufwerke gebaut
wenn ich total abgedreht gucken wenn er jetzt ein request auf seinen server schickt dann blinken
Dann blinken irgendwie alle Disks.
Ich weiß nicht warum, aber das ist wahrscheinlich ein typischer Fall von, weil es geht.
Ach hier, jetzt sieht man das Video, woran er das gebaut hat.
Er hat seine Floppy Drives.
welches auto fährst du eigentlich fahren fiat 500 e
37 minuten das kann ich jetzt nicht gucken
Ist zu lang.
Ah, ja, ja.
Kann man denn sonst noch hier...
Ne, das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Nein, das gucken wir jetzt auch nicht.
So viel verdient ein Headhunter.
I hate JavaScript.
Das wollte ich die ganze Zeit schon mal gucken.
Genau.
Da ging es doch darum, was...
Wie JavaScript
in Date Times passt.
Und wie abgedreht das ist.
Das gucken wir jetzt.
Gucken jetzt, was
Java mit Daytime treibt.
Boah, jetzt das JavaScript, wie du bist hier.
Eine Runde Cake JavaScript zum
ins Bett gehen, Leute.
Oder, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier? Was ist das denn?
Der ARD
Technologie Guide 1900. Okay, das
ist wieder, oh Gott, das ist wieder
YouTube, was die Titel übersetzt.
Ne, wir gucken, wir gucken, bevor wir
das JavaScript, wir gucken uns das Video jetzt mal an.
Ich guck gern so alten
Krempel, ey.
So was 1999 Bleeding Edge
war.
Was können Multifunktionsgeräte?
Das ist viel zu
high-res, das ist nicht aus der Original.
Versuchte industrie uns mit erfindungen zu beglücken die mehrere geräte in einem vereinen all in one nennt sie das
Ist das ein schallplatten spieler
Seit ende der 60er jahre waren das haben wir nicht
kompaktanlagen sehr erfolgreich doch das waffeleisen mit dem man zugleich tosten und grillen kann ließ sich nicht zurecht durchsetzen nicht
zu kriegen dagegen
werkzeugkombinationen wie das schweizer messer oder der bessere amerikanische leather man
Den gibt's heute auch noch.
Die Dinger sind richtig cool.
Wenn man vier verschiedene Werkzeuge mit einem Motor antreibt, wie beim Kombi-Gerät Black
& Decker Quattro, dann muss man wissen, dass das ein Kompromiss ist.
Das Element Stichsäge wird mit der Multiplex-Platte schlechter fertig.
Ja, das ist mir jetzt wurscht.
Ich warte eigentlich eher auf irgendwelchen Technikkram.
Was die Black & Decker Stichsäge macht, ist mir ziemlich egal.
Auch hier geht's los.
... in der Ratgeber-Technik-Geschichte nicht einigen können, was absolut unsinnig und was ganz sinnvoll ist.
Entscheiden Sie selbst.
Ich finde die Sprecher von damals immer so geil.
Die sprechen das alles so richtig krass korrekt aus und so super nah am...
Die sind doch alle immer so richtig nah am Mikrofon, wenn die sprechen.
...wecker ist und Nachrichten empfängt.
Klaus soll um zwölf...
Moment, welche Nachrichten empfängt die denn? Achso.
Äh, jetzt nicht
irgendwelche Mobile-Sachen, weil das
gab's ja, na doch, gab's damals auch schon.
Sondern irgendwelche...
Was ist das?
Was für Nachrichten?
...Ur Ursula treffen.
Oh, die Ursula.
Ursula hat dem Computer von Klaus eine E-Mail
geschickt. Und die Botschaft
ist gleich auf der Casio-Uhr gelandet.
Smartwatch, Leute!
... sich der Technikfreak.
Push, Push-Notification!
1999.
... hat Klaus seinen Frühstücksautomaten programmiert.
Der köpft selbsttätig Eier, brät sie, backt Toast und kocht auch noch Kaffee.
Und das alles zur richtigen Zeit am nächsten...
Okay, der Kram hat sich nicht durchgesetzt.
... morgen.
Nach dem Aufstehen liest Klaus erstmal die Zeitung.
Es gibt da schon Staubsauger-Roboter?
1999?
Ja, wie?
Staubsaugen, das macht sein Robo weg, ganz allein.
Robo weg, die Dinger heißen heute immer noch so.
Der Herr von Kärcher schafft nur 15 Faktoren pro Stunde.
Doch Zeit ist für ihn kein Thema.
Er saugt, wenn alle aus dem Haus sind, ganz langsam.
Aber so lange, bis kein Stäubchen mehr übrig ist.
1999, das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Auch unterm Schrank tummelt sich der 20 Watt Sauger.
Zwischendurch fährt er in seine Ladestation, tankt Energie und wird vom angesaugten Dreck befreit.
Nächstes Jahr kann ihn jeder für rund 900 Mark kaufen.
Jetzt ist das Frühstück so.
Ey, nicht schlecht, oder?
Das Ding fährt auch sogar zur Basisstation zurück und dockt sich an und alles.
Das ist doch nice für 1999.
Ich weiß, die Dinger waren damals natürlich nicht so intelligent wie heute.
Heute haben die teilweise eine Kamera, können Objekte erkennen und sowas.
Der damals ist wahrscheinlich einfach ziemlich dumm gegen die Wand, random links, rechts, gegen die Wand, random links, rechts gefahren.
900 Mark war damals richtig viel Geld.
Mark.
wäre es denn doch ein bisschen zu viel Lärm.
Und mit 730 Mark ist der Pro-ID-Versand da auch nicht gerade billig.
Gut, dass wir das jetzt wissen,
dass Ursula dann auf der Isomatte schlafen,
äh, auf der Luftmatratze schlafen muss.
Klaus greift sich seinen Caddy und die Kühlbox,
ab geht's ans Wasser.
Aus der Kühlkiste vom Versandhausschneider
wird ihm nur ein Tisch
und zwei Hocker sind auch drin versteckt.
Der Giga-Chat braucht seinen Schlaf-Chat.
Auf die Luftmacht-Katze.
Du kommst nicht in mein Bett.
Alles zusammen 149 Mark.
Nur die Transportliege für 80 Mark, ebenfalls von Schneider,
die ist mit 1,10 Meter Liegefläche etwas kurz geraten.
Das stört Klaus allerdings kaum,
hat er sich für die gute Laune doch die Sonnenbrille Sports geleistet.
geleistet. In dieser Idee aus
Hongkong steckt ein plärrendes Radio
für UKW und Mittelhelle.
Guck mal hier,
vorher haben wir die neue Smartwatch
von Zuckerberg gesehen.
Äh, nicht Smartwatch, Smartclass.
Das sind Smartclasses
aus 1999.
Klaus bestellt heute auf Temo,
ja. Kann ich mir vorhin schon richtig
vorstellen.
Können wir einen Kangaroo-Bot
haben? Was für ein Ding?
Was soll der machen?
Und wo bleibt Ursula?
Klaus schaut auf seine vom Satellit gesteuerte Casio Uhr, die auch den Kompass ersetzt. Er sei 35 Grad nördlich,
139 Grad Ost, so schreibt Ursula auf seinem Handy von Nokia und schickt die Meldung per E-Mail ab. Doch Ursula
versetzt ihn.
Keck, wait.
Auf der Rückfahrt noch eine Panne.
Doch mit Musik geht bekanntlich alles besser.
Alter, was für sinnlose Gadgets, man.
Ein Radio im Werkzeugkoffer und die Taschenlampe mit Radio und Uhr.
Das sind wirklich geniale Kombierfindungen.
Naja.
Nur schade, dass der Werkzeugkoffer aus Hongkong für deutsches Werkzeug ein wenig zu klein geraten ist.
klaus damals kam sachen aus hongkong heute kommt egal was sie kauft kommt also schenzen
aus frustriert schaltet er den fernseher an ein bierchen dazu wäre jetzt nicht schlecht
seine philipps tour de france 1999 fernbedienung macht ihm leicht denn die ist gleichzeitig ein
Flaschenöffner. Nur,
bekleckern verträgt die Elektronik
noch schlechter als ihr Tablet.
Ja, das ist ja wirklich absolut sinnlos.
Was ist das hier?
Klecker.
Neben solch zweifelhaften
Multitalenten gibt es auch wirklich
zukunftsweisende Technologien.
Zum Beispiel diese Mikrowelle von
Deju. Fertiggericht aus
der Packung in den Teller,
entsprechende Magnetkarte gewählt
und die Automatik weiß,
ob sie garen, grillen
oder backen muss und wie lange es dauert.
Das könnte gewiss schön bequem sein,
wenn es denn auf Anhieb...
Ja, damals waren Mikrowellen so der neuste Shit.
Oh, die juckt eigentlich...
Also, ich meine, wir haben ja auch eine Mikrowelle.
Ich glaube, ich habe das ganze letzte Jahr
eins, zweimal irgendwie die Mikrowelle benutzt,
um irgendwas langsam aufzutauen.
Das war's.
... funktionieren würde, aber das kommt hoffentlich noch.
Hat der Start geklappt, ist in gut drei Minuten alles fertig.
Dieser Löwe-Fernseher ist nicht nur breit, Format 16 zu 9, er bringt sie auch...
Ja, 16 zu 9 war damals voll modern.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was die...
Was war dann die 16 zu 9-Parl-Auflösung?
Es war nicht wirklich Palme, es waren dann 720x568 oder irgendwie sowas.
Knopfdruck ins Internet und mach den zusätzlichen Computer.
Was? Ins Internet?
1999 auf dem Fernseher? Was ist da für ein Browser drauf?
Mosaik oder was?
Überflüssig. Rechts oben weiterhin das Fernsehbild.
Ist das der Internet Explorer, Leute?
Sieht aus wie ein Internet Explorer, oder?
Ja, er ist Internet Explorer.
Ach du Kacke.
Naja, das macht nicht wirklich den Computer überflüssig.
Das war aber schon eine Art Smart TV.
Ne, lesen kann man da nicht wirklich was drauf.
Das liegt aber auch an der schlechten Auflösung von dem Beitrag.
Also es könnte durchaus sein, dass das ganz brauchbar ist.
Also...
Das war so ein...
So ein Bleeding Edge Ding.
Damals...
Ich frag mich ja, wie das Ding ins Internet gekommen ist.
Hatte das ein Modem drin?
Oder...
musste das quasi damals an Router angeschlossen werden schon und das Modem an Routes.
Ich würde mich jetzt mal interessieren, wie die das damals gemacht haben.
Picture in Picture plus TV können heute sogar nur wenige.
Weiß ich gar nicht, ich habe das bei meinen noch nie ausprobiert.
Ich benutze das Smart TV OS nicht.
Da ist ja ein Android-TV drauf auf meinem Fernseher.
Hab ich noch nicht einmal benutzt.
Ich hab da mein Shield-TV dran.
Das hat ja auch ein Android-TV drauf.
Und mach alles da drüber.
Die Bedienung ist auch viel zackiger und so.
Und da gibt es auf jeden Fall kein Internet-TV-Picture-in-Picture.
Da haben wir es.
Modem.
PC. Selbst
Homebanking ist so... So ein richtig nice
56K Modem.
...wem Bankgeschäfte über T-Online
oder das Internet trotz
vieler Warnungen vom Ratgeber Technik
nicht zu gefährlich sind, kann
sie... Achtung,
Achtung.
...bequem machen. Über kabellose
Tastatur wird überwiesen.
Dem Fernsehton...
Sehe ich richtig, dass es BTX ist?
Das ist doch kein Internet,
was ich da sehe.
Ist das Telekom BTX noch?
Kann man dabei weiter lauschen.
Wer sich vor vielen Tasten nicht grundsätzlich fürchtet,
erwirbt mit diesem Farbtintenstrahldrucker von Brother ein siebenfaches Multitalent.
Guter Hersteller.
Ein siebenfaches Multifunktionsgerät.
Okay, lass mal überlegen.
Drucken, scannen, kopieren, faxen.
Äh
Ähm
Chat
Fax hab ich doch schon
Telefon, ja Telefon, richtig Chat
Ihr habt bestimmt recht, Telefon
Fünf
Anrufbeantworter sechs, gute Idee
Gute Idee Chat, das wird's wahrscheinlich sein
Sechs
Ich weiß echt nicht was das
Lass es uns mal erzählen
Das Gerät druckt, faxt und kopiert farbig.
Ja.
Es hat Telefon, einen Anrufbeantworter, druckt von digitalen Videos und Fotoapparaten auf Knopfdruck Bilder aus
und ersetzt die Pinnwand, wenn man in den Textspeicher zu Hause eine Nachricht spricht.
Ersetzt die was?
Ersetzt die Pinnwand?
Wie jetzt?
Das habe ich nicht kapiert.
Man sagt an dem Drucker,
irgendwie to do,
morgen einkaufen oder was.
Hä?
Kiffst du eigentlich? Nein, mache ich nicht.
Hallo, ich bin's.
Ich wollte nur sagen, ich komme...
Gleich kommt Ursula auch vorbei.
...und erst um 18 Uhr. Bis dann.
Was war das bei deinem TV? Was meinst du?
Hallo, ich sollte mal sagen, ich gucke heute 11.18 Uhr. Bis dann.
Was für ein sinnloses Feature.
Platz sparen im Auto. Dieses Motto beherzigt Alpine und kombiniert Radio,
OCD und DVD mit
einem Fernseher. Hoffentlich haben sie
noch Hand und Kopf frei für die Fernbedienung.
Das TV-Gerät
schaltet während der Fahrt ab.
Da hilft einem...
Das ist ja wie heute.
Achso, das OS, mein Fernseher
und Android-TV. Aber ich benutze
das Android-TV nicht, sondern ich habe ein Shield-TV
dran. Das Nvidia Shield.
Und das hat auch Android-TV.
Das ist wie
heute.
Heute ist das auch so, dass du keine Videos gucken kannst über...
Wie heißt das Kram?
Äh, Apple Car? Nee.
Wie heißt das Zeug?
Oder Android Auto... CarPlay. Genau, CarPlay meine ich.
Kannst keine Videos gucken. Und bei Android kannst du glaube ich YouTube gucken, aber es geht auch beim Fahren aus oder sowas.
Ja, gerade noch mal Glück gehabt, ne?
Aber es gab heute schon so viele Subs.
Der Chat hat schon ziemlich
Plus IQ gemacht heute.
Oh!
1999.
Navigation.
Guck mal, das war ja
voll advanced schon.
Blitengesteuert erreicht man so jedes Ziel.
Gleich nach rechts.
Nach den vorhin gezeigten schlechten Erfahrungen mit nachts brennenden Brotbackautomaten
fragt man sich wirklich, ob das restliche Frühstück auch noch vor dem Wecken angeworfen werden muss.
Wenigstens funktionieren sollten die Kombigeräte ja.
Doch der C-Pen-Lesestift hatte bei uns schon Schwierigkeiten mit dem Lesen.
So konnte auch nach dem Scannen nichts Vernünftiges bei der Kombifunktion Übersetzen rauskommen.
Der im Film gezeigte Multifunktions-Farbdrucker von Brother, der auch faxt und Anrufe beantwortet, funktioniert besser.
Und der kostet nur 1200 Mark, während man...
Und was kostet die Tinte? Das ist doch bestimmt ein Tintenstrahldrucker.
...für alle sieben Einzelgeräte zusammen...
Wobei, ich bin mir gar nicht mehr so sicher, ob das ein Tintenstrahldrucker ist.
...2200 Mark...
Doch, oder? Das wird ein Tintenstrahldrucker sein.
Haben die gesagt?
Okay.
Er kann Farbe meinen, Laser kann auch Farbe.
Liste bei uns abfordern, wenn sie uns
einen mit einer Mark 10 frankierten
Frei-Umschlag schicken.
Ja, das war damals so.
Da war noch nichts mit, man geht mal kurz
ins Internet und guckt danach.
Da musste man dann noch einen Brief
hinschicken
mit einem frankierten Rückumschlag
und dann haben die dir was zugeschickt.
Das habe ich übrigens auch einmal gemacht.
Ich habe mal
einen Brief geschickt an die Sendung
mit der Maus.
Und da habe ich ein paar Sticker, ein paar Maus-Sticker bekommen.
Da habe ich mich mega gefreut damals.
Die Sendung mit der Maus war eh beste.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es die noch gibt.
Chat, ich muss in 5 Minuten.
Nee, off.
Gibt's noch irgendwas Wichtiges?
Musst du ins Bett? Nee, noch nicht.
5 Minuten Video.
Na, wie 1973 Autofahren früher.
Oh ne, oder?
Das war noch zu Zeiten, wo sie sich drüber aufgeregt haben, dass es eine Gurtpflicht geben soll.
Schaust du bitte noch nach dem Backup?
Ja, mache ich jetzt, sobald ich hier
sobald ich hier off bin.
Mal mal die VM aus.
Ich gucke jetzt gleich mal, ob das Backup
funktioniert hat.
Chat, schön, dass ihr dabei wart. Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream. Macht's gut, bis dann. See you.